you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy master bucks
no no just cool this checks okay this
mouse makes money with words and he is
getting money dude I appreciate you
taking the time to even do this
appreciate you man I also can't hear out
of these Oh DJ oh now we are here we are
now we aren't yeah I'm good man were
super loud - maybe I just gave all the
juice too - yeah man the white man I was
on your podcast more than culture and I
opened up with art here comes the
colonizers everything you got ever
brought me to the tree now the gravel I
was like ah [ __ ] where's my pistol now
bring you back to England as let me show
me yeah yes good this is among Garner
man he's the man with the plan oh my god
bassist slash engineer well you may be
soon I see you got a tambourine over
there only people that make let you
slide we've done the trap in uh we did
internet radio a minute ago to some
three knows for me was four years ago
for you all I know is that I was still
wearing dress pants dress pant because
like I was under the impression I was
like it's just clothes - pajamas as I
can get without it being actual pajama
pants right wrinkle resistant cotton
Dockers the white man's joggers I
I had to get married and come up ray oh
yeah oh so your wife made you start
wearing as you she never made me do
anything she always just let me work it
out myself
just drop subtle hints that's how I know
she loves me is cuz she knew me with the
moustache she knew me were rocking
Hindley's and dress pants and Rockport's
yeah I was all the way out her out
shouts my wife Aaron Byers she also made
the theme song for hot breath whoo and
we have a podcast called Byers life -
yeah not ain't that ain't the thing
though you devout you one I found me a
real one I know your little [ __ ] you're
a little busy to have a real one right
now I guess you got you work yeah man
yeah yeah I'm too busy correct - I've
been very fortunate enough to have my
work be appreciated and people wanna and
that's what on the on our first
interview which is like episode 90 we
record this actually 140 what come on
man let him do it
we've moved the last time I interviewed
you I had labeled water but it was
labels I made and then now we got hooked
up by a fonta swatter oh we got our own
Georgia spring water you're educated
escape man
font is exclusive so that's your water
to take with you I got my one over there
so I'll take both oh yeah you can do
whatever you sponsored now boy got his
own water look at you forty-nine cents
and it was cool to interview now is
you're making another big transition is
the first time we interviewed each other
which is just a little over a year ago I
interviewed you and it was you were in
this new beginning of a transition right
just started a TV show you just started
this tour you're doing and now both are
on another level yeah
yes yeah I can't believe it's been a
year since we started that like bosib
only TV was just filmed in Atlanta was
started around this time last summer and
that rent went really well so they
picked it up again it's gonna be an hour
long Oh instead of 30 minutes that make
it an hour coming on Thursdays after the
Braxtons Family Values which is the most
popular show on a network which is
really dope so yeah and then I'm be
moving to LA in a couple days to to film
start doing that and you know with the
with the tour it's kind of little it
rose but now it's kind of on hold
because they're all three of us are busy
right now on there awhile and now
reminding myself with bicep but we plant
we have some dates sin um Connie in
August pretty much yeah August pretty
much from August on through the fall and
stuff so yeah it's been great man this
is like when you can see the work like
look yeah thank you seeing the work
right right straight up before you came
to my house with your phone and no video
man no video yeah no video had a little
microphone like you kept going you keep
going you put working now you have 140
insane
yeah in this video it's so dope yeah
part of what you inspired me is thinking
of the vision and where you want to be
okay is that you think that still plays
a big part in your success now yeah yeah
yeah yeah cuz a lot of stuff that I'm
doing is something I talked about saw or
somebody told me that they can see me
doing it's always it's always been
something so like stuff that's happening
is awesome but it's not surprising I'm
waiting for so even in the long days
like you know working oh I didn't
mention working a while and out season
coming up season 12 I'm a creative
consultant which means I write for Nick
Cannon and then pretty much all the
special guests to come on the show and
some of the cast me everybody on show we
write for the producer too now but yeah
so that's cool and
they actually driving me in a few
episodes this shirt yeah yeah I shot my
first episode a couple days ago because
you were just killing it because I was
just surprised at all you know what was
crazier than that though it was before I
was even killing it so I they you know
they commissioned us to come it myself
and Clayton English shout out both been
on here ATL comedy no doubt saying
both of us are creative consultants on
the show so we all do the same thing and
the first day before we even like
started to warm up with the new talent
or anything
Nick Cannon walked over to both of us
and was like you know letting us know
what he wanted from us like in terms of
how to help with the new people and he
was like yeah but make sure y'all jump
into some of the games that were
practicing because we're gonna put y'all
on some episodes so this is like before
we even started okay
so that was that was refreshing that was
a real dope dope moment and I also do
crowd warm up to let me do that if I
have some time when I'm not prepping the
special guests before the show I'll go
out there and do about ten minutes for
the crowd get them hyped so are you like
you're the guest comes in let's I mean
the guest it's all the celebrities who
ever go on wild and out yes Robert
were the people who I had to prep for
the show man
okay so the first show was very strong
today we're late as hell obviously no no
doubt yeah but they were they were great
man they had been on the show already so
it wasn't too much how late were they
though as hell and white people are
sprinting so we got the media know when
they're long but they are talented
because they didn't have that long
before they got onstage to do their mic
check in the show but they went and did
their thing on the show like they're
good with improv they were coming back
on the rap part so that was dope
Ludacris was like super prepared you
know so what I would say super prepared
but like he read the email looked at the
videos that we sent him is earned
in terms of examples like he was ready
he hit Nick with a couple shots like in
the during the games and in the wild
style and then IOT Genesis you know I'm
saying he was he was really cool he
played some of the games he even played
the props game so it was dope just to
see like these hardcore rappers yeah
[ __ ] playing the props improv game
you know what I'm saying they like
nervous before the show like you know
some of them are like uh I would say I
wouldn't say nert nervous is probably
not the right word but they just kind of
like curious about how it's gonna go you
know Santa's like it's funny because you
would think like the rapper's since the
show is mostly about kind of like
freestyle improv but to a beat a lot of
the games you would think they're like
fit right in but a lot of them don't do
that a lot of rappers don't battle rap
they don't freestyle they don't go back
and forth you know what I'm saying and
then there's like a faction of battle
rappers that actually do that all the
time so you know there'll be a little
nervous about that like a man ain't
freestyle a long time and you know is
live and it's one shot if I stand up you
know what I mean they only give you one
shot there's no I mean they may go back
a little bit if something's too messed
up or some technical stuff but other
than that is so it's real it's real
improv you know this live is one shot
deal you mess up you you out you messed
up you know I mean so yeah they do get a
little bit anxious I would say I imagine
and you being like their their contact
point yeah yeah we come out after the
break after every game make sure they
know what they're supposed to say to the
next game or if they're gonna get in Wow
run it by us again
so yeah it's pretty cool it's pretty
cool day and they're like they cling to
us a little bit you could tell the ones
that are little boys like hey what's
going on me how'd I do like Dwight
Howard he was on do I Howard he was dope
he was though he you know he's goofy so
he was really into it you know I'm
saying so he was fun to work with he he
had some we rode him like a wild style
and it's pretty good and he liked it but
when the show started he did his own
thing and it was like boom it's cool
about seeing behind the scenes of wild
and out and I've interviewed a couple
I've ever you derrin like you referenced
and Jacob Williams who's on there
AJ came out to cats when I hosted yeah
yeah he did my show the next night and
then he hopped on the podcast I told him
about ok good I'm glad he went up that's
dope yeah he was very he's so unassuming
in life it's always I think Darren did
an Instagram story of like the after
party never seen one I don't care what
color you are music is on for 4 hours
straight and everybody here was you guys
it was cool to see the behind the scenes
of it being filmed in Atlanta and
everybody posting videos and wildin out
seems like this completely just off the
rails show but you guys rehearsed like
in the hotel like oh yeah yes here's a
workshop so yeah it's needed because a
lot of the people especially the new
cast members are trying to think of the
right way they're not performers per se
they're Instagram stars so everything
they do is to a phone rings recorded
they haven't done any live shows in
front of crowds so you got it you know
it takes a while and then now you got
two weeks basically to give someone a
crash course and improv and stand up and
singing and rapping so yeah it's pretty
it's a pretty intense situation but it's
good like it's good to see them grow you
feel like a coach you know I'm saying
cause like you give them good jokes but
it's the delivery you know I'm saying
that's the main disconnect with people
that that don't live and die on stage I
shout out the moat Williams mope is
doing well yeah yeah on the show and I
believe it's mostly due to he doesn't
have as many followers as everybody else
but it's mostly due to him living and
dying on stage you can't you can't you
can't substitute those you know those
feelings right there and yeah and
pushing through both like being humble
enough to let the good times know like I
still need to work on this and this and
this or going through the bad times like
okay that was just a bad time I could
push through or fixing a bad time in the
middle of the bad time on stage you know
and learning how to do that so you can
see it and people that don't do that
they go up and they mess up and then you
can see it affect them every time they
get back up again
they started to kind of shrink a little
bit yeah because they never have that
they've never won or lost
everything's been everything I post hi
hi this is so funny you're the greatest
right so we have to have to kind of
break down and build up that's why I
love stand up because I feel like it
prepares you for everything everything
you wanna be a writer you want to be an
actor you want to be a director you'll
be an editor you'll get prepared you for
all that yeah I never feel like I feel I
never feel out of place no matter what
gig I'm getting you know I'm saying like
if it's writing producing anything
acting whatever hosting I never feel out
of place because of stand-up mmm and
especially Atlanta stand-up doing
stand-up here and all the play on all
the weird places that we have the types
of people that we have to make laughs
and the types of environments that we're
in and also being around other really
sharp really dope comedians all of that
together just prepares us for you know
the blow up which is what you're
currently experiencing come on now I
feel like I feel like I feel like I have
the tank the helium tank you know saying
[Music]
you about to jump to LA yes indeed a
film season 2 of your show yes indeed
that's a big leap a lot of comedians
think about and hear about is okay it's
time to move to LA or New York what are
you what are you experiencing right now
what do you feeling well go up real
quick going back vision wise yeah I
don't know if it was something I would
talk about a lot but you know in the
comedy community everybody as you may or
says you need to move that layer when
you're moving their leg and I would
always say when I get moved there that
was always my answer so it's the I'm
saying there's nothing until I feel -
you feel me yes so when it came to
fruition so that's that's what I'm
feeling right now that's dope that that
came about and I'm really excited
because once again I'm really fortunate
to and blessed to be on television for
my first times and be being myself you
know what I mean it's cool to be an
actor or whatever but if you can be
yourself on TV and then write for
yourself it just makes it more natural
so so I'm really happy about that and
they're putting a lot
on our shoulders creative wise and
producing wise for this show so a lot of
myself annum and Ronnie's DNA was on the
show last year and it'll be on the show
again this year it was a really dope I
think when does it need to do you want
to wait oh yeah I can say this I believe
they're gonna have like a segment with
me and Ronnie interviewing people in in
the car okay innuendo of the California
grocery though it's only on brand come
on now homie lazy I like five days apart
in age but I'm so jealous you guys can
get high and do stuff I had to quit
because I just can't do both I'm glad
you quit I hate you started it's one of
those things I just I guess just kind of
grew out of where my brains like nah and
sometimes my thing is this what you
think about weed is what we it is so if
you think we know seriously so if you
think you're gonna be to eat that's what
weed is for you if you think you need
weed to be funny that's what we do is
for you if you think we've freaks you
out that's what we do is for you you
know what I'm saying like it's such a
cerebral drug that whatever you think
about it is probably what you're gonna
feel about it but there's some comics
and it could be like you know some
people have to drink before they go
onstage some people have to smoke before
they go onstage but for like a younger
comic would you almost be like I would
recommend going up sober so you don't
create like that kind of range I
remember clayton talking to a young
comic when I was kind of like I was in
the game for about three years of things
so I was had a good handle on it but I
remember him talking to one coming she
was saying that she you know always
needed we need to go up cuz they're like
comms are down and he was saying I
suggest that you do a few shows sober
for
those times where you won't be able to
smoke you know like if you're in a arena
or you know Convention Center or just
where it's not appropriate to smoke
you're gonna need to know that you can
do this right so that's my advice passed
down from Clayton English I mean I smoke
all the time so it wasn't really a thing
for me but if the comedian's out there
they're like me and I smoke all the time
do sober shows you know enough to know
that all right I can do it you know I'm
saying it's fine
because then if you're fortunate enough
to make it on TV filming and prep lasts
so long
unless you're smoking on your show
you're probably not gonna be hired by
the time they say action yeah some
people don't see on TV is oh it's a
half-hour show but it's like oh that one
shot took three hours yeah yeah for sure
for sure and now that you're on your own
show you're actually like kind of the
face of the show as well like you're the
middle you're like the quarterback right
I won't say that publicly but nah but
like I said they do they do put a lot of
my shoulders in terms of creating the
segments and you know letting me say
what I want to say and helping people
out you know with the funny because if
we could back it up on even know if I
said this last podcast were like boss
them kind of started leaning towards
funny when we did this we did this pilot
episode episodic pilot for basa but it
was it was more like a sitcom so it was
written episodes and then we did like
seven of them and you know they're
supposed to be funny they didn't really
pick it up but they liked me and kept me
on that bicep for the website so I was
doing like just funny terms on on what
the stories that they had so then they
came back and was like well what if we
just do like a kind of reality live
funny show about it with the guy he got
you know I'm saying so and it was all
right cool we'll do it cuz they try to
push the sitcom like hard hard hard but
nobody really was because it was hard to
do that sitcom about current events and
then you tape it and then it comes
three months later and exactly
non-current so now they decided all
right let's do a show we film it one day
and it comes out the next day so it's
current as hell but we got to make you
funny because that's the thing people
come to buy some now especially on their
Twitter like their headlines are killing
like even New York Times wrote about
their writers and the headlines that
they write whoa they'll get people to
respond they'll get on your skin or the
[ __ ] just be so funny their
alliteration is crazy hey shout out to
all the like you follow possible on
Twitter you need to brace hilarious no
but shout out to all the cat the writers
over there at Bossip that worked for the
actual website super dope evil super
funny super creative you mentioned
getting under people's skin have you
have personal experience with that any
blowback uh yeah it didn't come straight
to me it came to legal for the show like
2:00 in the morning the film an apology
clip for Smokey Robinson of all people
so I'm trying to make this short story
[ __ ] shorter oh so I did a segment we
have we have not only the bull pen
segment like TMZ has but we also have
the wedding like TMZ but we sit the
people look at it like we're sitting in
the office pitching stories for that
we're gonna be writing for today but the
other segment is standing in front of a
green screen with one particular topic I
had a topic and it was bicep for your
granny so it was about older celebrities
you know I'm saying so I had to think
about Dionne Warwick and Aretha Franklin
having beef another story I can't
remember was and then one story about it
was reported and it's this article that
that Smokey Robinson was single
he's like 70 something right so I made
up something about you know a lot of old
women chasing them and all that stuff
his wife must've got mad oh and sent
something to legal I mean to us and was
like yeah you know he's happily married
and you know you don't need to be
spreading false rumors so I had to go
back and film apology because of that so
it reached them
I also did a
I did the thing about Mariah Carey you
know I'm saying it wouldn't mean I know
it was funny but you know when people
have like real fanatics instead of fans
they're gonna go get some blowback
sometimes like if somebody don't get
this black gum bastard that was the
funniest comeback and then one dude was
like then he had did a quote from
somebody talk about dudes gossip in like
bicep in like something I forgot what it
was makes the same box by women but in
his picture his profile picture he was
like sucking on a straw out of a cup I
was like yeah it takes one to know one
[Music]
that's just saying keeping it alive you
got to be the only one keeping their
lives dude my class every week I did a
week one I do it every single week they
wait on telling you you got to be the
only one they need to like slide you
some residual I'll take that I'll put
I'll put on my vision board yeah that's
what we went in on deep at the last
episode of pause you went into detail
about your vision board and how specific
you are on what you're trying to achieve
correct how you're trying to attain it
yes yes for anybody I didn't catch less
last episode that I was on [ __ ] you know
one number two I was talking about you
know some people say I want to be an
actor I want to be a comedian I want to
be a singer so I read this book [ __ ]
which one was it was it think yeah Think
and Grow Rich and it gave me it helped
me out with my vision board in terms of
all right you know what you want to do
what's the steps to get there so I was
being very specific on how I'm gonna get
these steps like I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna write on something every day
I'm gonna create something everyday I'm
gonna try to write a new joke I'm gonna
try to write a new story I'm gonna try
to comment on a current event and make
you funny even if I don't post it or do
it I just want to make sure I do it and
that's why I was going up to the studio
that you can do two more
more than culture podcast hey and I was
doing that every day and this was
creating and creating and you know
making my opportunities people see me
working all that together with the
vision is you know what I feel like
really helped me get to where I'm at you
know and what you were talking about a
year ago is what is happening now it's
crazy yes one of the specific things you
said was the Bossip show just started
and you're like we're doing a six
episode trial run I'm seeing this pig
getting picked up and going in multiple
seasons
yeah I'm season two yeah yeah la season
two right now we got a ten episode deal
which is dope they moved it up to an
hour like I said they're putting they're
linking us with the number one show on
the network already and it's you know
hopefully we get some of their fans off
top mm-hmm and yes it's just the works
been working the work has been working
man so and it's one of those shows that
could be like all right it's popular we
like it it's a current event show it's
now news so we could possibly come on
once a week for the whole year yeah you
know it's possible to do that and when
people see you on a TV show all they see
is you on screen being funny what are
some of the behind the scenes work
people may not realize is they're all
the writing number one that goes into it
they do they did a good job the first
season that was like making it look
really natural and it kind of was
because we kept our our our comments of
what we were gonna say to ourselves so
that we could get a ret natural reaction
the research that goes into it our
research and production or whatever you
want to call it team finding stories
making sure they're true you know we'd
really check in with legal on some of
these things you know cuz this is you
get sue for saying false things about
people on TV so that's another thing
running through writing stuff through
Eagle is another thing people don't
don't get and then you have some jokes
that you think are crazy good and then
since the turnaround is so fast you
won't know it but the next day won't
make it mean they're like yeah we had to
cut it last minute legal was said that
out of that like we had to rely is AB
like 17 are Kelly stories last year and
we did a bunch of jokes on him in the
only one that really made it on air was
me putting the mask on yeah he usually
wears really made it so that's that's a
lot of stuff that people don't don't
really know and when a TV show when
you're saying I'm going to LA to film a
TV show is the show like physically
moving you're out there they're paying
for everything and all that yeah yeah
we're talking before we got on air a lot
of people you know when you're doing
comedy and I guess smaller markets in
Atlanta is a big comedy market but it's
a smaller entertainment market for now
it's on the way out for sure but people
are like yeah when you move in LA when
you move into New York and I answer
would always be when I get moved out
there so that part of the vision that
part of you know putting that in the
atmosphere is now coming to fruition
it's like now they're like okay we'd
like to show it was filmed in Atlanta I
think it cost them a little bit less to
film it in LA running people behind the
scenes wise so like we're gonna bring
you know the cast out to LA and film is
themed we're gonna put you up they
putting us up like not that far away
from the studio I'm talking about to say
not that great oh I don't know the the
different arrangements should be good
because a lot of people that that are
there for short term doing filming and
stuff like that a lot of actors writers
producers there they stay in the same
building and so it's like a college dorm
for entertainment Damon yeah so that
should be pretty dope and we're a few
feet from like when a few feet but
walking distance from like CBS Studios
and Paramount and all those things are
like right in the area yeah right at the
bottom of Beverly Hills if I'm not
mistaken Oh a long way from Inglewood
yeah yeah not physically but yeah
yeah where you are now yes the
congratulations man
thank you brother I appreciate it man
you know you've been there for a while
you've seen the process see the process
you know now yeah man and that's why I
think is it's a good note for people
it's just like you said the work is
working the work is working man don't
don't ever stop it cuz you won't see it
I feel like something I've recently
learned is to just focus on being funny
mm-hmm and then let your opportunities
come through that as opposed to like why
isn't this happening right yeah I don't
yeah cuz I mean there's a few people
that have I think they're just gonna
like force things to happen for them I
just don't feel like I was one of those
people so that's why I say go with that
go with the funny and then things will
happen for you but there's some people
who that just that really like forced so
I think like the Instagram comedians is
probably the best example I can give in
terms of like they're gonna force
themselves on you like you're gonna see
videos from them people gonna be
reposting them you know that they're
constant with it they're constant with
even if it's like I think I know for a
fact some of them put stuff out just
because they need to have a video out
that day they don't care about if it's
as funny as the last one or you know I'm
right helping themselves they just they
just have to do it but that's part of
them putting themselves out there to the
world like hey I'm here I'm here to our
boy you're putting ourselves out to the
world is you know we hitting hitting the
stage as we hitting the stage that we're
here we're here somebody's gonna see
this somebody's going to need my pen
somebody's gonna need the way I perform
at some point and you know that's how it
be not so much like okay everybody in
the world you see everything I do yeah
it's two different sizes
yeah you talked about auditioning for a
while now but not having quote enough
followers and now a year later you're on
while they're now that's crazy man
that's so cool yeah man yeah I think I
think it's a lesson in everything coming
with time you know I'm saying in your
time cuz like so say if I'm a while now
I may not have had the the opportunity
to get the Bossip show you
saying which is a show that I could
control a lot of you know I'm saying the
Wilin out is you might get a moment or
two here but I'm on the whole show one
hour
you feel me yeah and I've started
posting questions or like asking the hot
breath reverse for questions about my
guests as before they're coming up okay
and one of them was actually from a Jay
Ward J shout out the Jay war man Jay war
makes me feel like the best comedian in
the world like every every one of two
years on on Facebook he'll drop
something more like I'll post something
underneath people hey man you're the
best meeting the world appreciate you
[Laughter]
this question was in short he had
something on his show Sweetwater and how
is it grandfathered in because he's been
doing it so long but the main question
was why is your desk higher on bosses
that was a compromise they have
everybody else sitting and I think I'm
funnier when I'm standing up so I asked
him if they could give me a stand-up
desk and they were saying like okay well
I mean I was like can I just stand up
behind some [ __ ] because I did it on the
sizzle but there's like nah but we could
get you because it's supposed to be like
an office setting we suppose you're
really working and in in the morning we
have a meeting like all right what's
good enough to make this website today
mm-hmm so it's a video she is supposed
to be you know filming of us in the
office so they try to make it a little
more office he so they just gave me a
high table with a stool cool so I could
sit down a little bit but I'm still like
standing up inside baseball there yes
because that was that was a discussion
that was a mold see that's like the
behind-the-scenes stuff yeah just see oh
this is happening and it's perfectly
library and they and it was I mean you
know I'm not even done it's only reason
it was a discussion was because in the
sizzle I stood up and they liked it
obviously the network liked it but they
wanted me to sit down for
next one solid and why when they liked
me standing up and I like standing up
yeah so it was cooler still is good
though I like it yeah I had to do that
I've been filming stuff for The Weather
Channel
odo and we were sitting down on the
first one yeah the next one I was like
he let me stand up for this one and I
stood up for all the rest of them
Samantha Faulk bring it name ring a bell
okay good no I always I'm saying she she
worked on Bossip for the production
company and she was telling me that The
Weather Channel was like looking for
comedians to do certain things so I
didn't know if she you know was involved
or you met her up there
oh no they they saw me at a performant
laughing school got it got it and
reached out from there oh yeah you know
Byron Allen bought Weather Channel yes
correct yeah that's what she was telling
me so they would like they're leaning a
little more towards trying to make it
look everybody's leaning towards funding
like you can't see it's a personal these
days without it trying to make you laugh
first exactly but not even these days
it's been like last 10 years when they
trying to make funny commercials and
stuff so everybody's leaning towards
funny and even the huddled Trump lucky
for us we're in the funny business man
for sure yeah everybody's coming towards
us yes we're here we're ready for you so
another question we had from the hot
breath of urgency let's go breath averse
[ __ ] with y'all I think my hive name
from this show dinner your hive name
yeah you know you got the hot breath
what was it chronic ins yeah chronic
help with at the end of the last episode
shout-out to the chronic ins and the
Brethren's
we got to have a squad we got - we ain't
nothing without them even though I post
it in like four people responded but
it's all good and one of the questions
was just like yeah that's true I'm sorry
I don't know why I was I was you know
alright in when you think of vision and
where you know you're going to be it's
just those almost almost enjoy like I
just did a show in South Carolina in
front of four people my name was spelled
wrong on the flyer but hey I got paid in
cash up front
it was it covered well over any expenses
there you go where was it Anderson
Anderson in a shopping small but
shopping small there were four people
including the Booker but I was like
those are the kind of moments that I'm
that make me appreciate I'm like yes I
need to appreciate these moments because
this is what's gonna make you where you
want to be correct correct definitely
you got to appreciate those moments I
appreciated one was all the time like
being able to make four and five and
nine people laugh onstage is helpful
yeah and that was like my one of my
first like I did like 45 minutes and
that was one of the only sets I've been
able to go that long I've been trying to
get more headlight upset it's a whole
other game it's like so we just told me
that shoutout to James Davis oh yeah
Jason he's in town he was doing a comedy
theater and we were just talking about I
don't know how he got into it but in
terms of like when you start becoming a
headlining comedian it's like dang am I
supposed to be the headliner right and
then it's like damn can I like to do I
have enough time but you got a that's
one of those things you definitely just
got to do yeah I never know when you're
ready until you start doing it
yeah and in doing 45 50 you're all the
way out on the highway before you know
no control when I interviewed Carlos
Miller on here he was talking about not
being fly-by-night funny was his quote
and he's like you gotta be funny he's
like are you funny enough he's like when
it's 12:30 and five local X when I'm
doing all their best stuff can you go up
there and be funny for an hour do you
have what it takes he was like all like
super Yoda about talking about
and it's real like I think stand-up in
general is something you you can watch
all the YouTube videos you want but you
literally you can ride all the jokes you
want but you have to stand in front of
that crowd mmm you gotta take the
punches
yes like a boxer to come a heavyweight
you gotta take the punches because your
improv game is something I've seen grow
over the years from just kind of
interaction with a crowd when you would
host cloud nine right now like so that
you can improv just on topics and make
them funny yeah yeah that's that's one
thing I've been blessed we're doing the
hosting my own rooms in Atlanta like you
said at cloud 9 I've hosted it every
foot I just realized that every comedy
show that was on Peter Street for the
last probably nine years I probably
hosted it yeah like Escobar slice 255
pearl did something once
cloud9 obviously old lady game I did
something once at the Mexican spot I
can't think of the name of it right now
there's another place that's like on
there but in the back they had something
my hosted a concert in there so I
started off with improv - that's another
thing if you're out there and you got
improv class to take you got Joel's
class on the take you got Rodney Perry
class to take I say you take them
because those things just learning how
to write in your head while things are
happening is huge it's huge and I know
you teach that and then Ronnie teach
that an improv that I did with snack
pack help me with that so now when I'm
up there by myself like I can make a big
room small like I told you I'm doing
warm-up for a while and out mmm but I'm
doing crowd work I might do a joke or
two here or there but I'll start off
with where you from or are you in a
relationship and then I can make that
funny move to the next person okay what
you do for a living and make that funny
you know what I'm saying so and that's
just from hosting all the time crowd
work can be intimidating do you have any
tips on that have a few in your pocket
that you know that you can say if you've
got a good relationship joke
if you've got a good joke about an
occupation or people were just working
9:00 to 5:00 in general that's a good to
have in your pocket if you have a good
joke about like said couples or race
maybe you know I'm saying maybe
interracial stuff just have like four
three three four or five jokes that you
really like that are general and maybe
you can apply it to people or just if
you got somebody that's really into it
just dig in and sometimes the more
questions you ask the funnier [ __ ] gets
I don't know what I don't know what it
is about that but you know you tried
before like I'm sure you've been married
how long how'd you meet you know did you
ever cheat like this get funnier with
the more questions you ask so and I just
say don't be scared don't be scared to
do it a lot of people are scared to get
off track and get off there get off
their set they practice in the mirror
don't be scared if you're if you're
doing comedy you believe you're funny
already that's the first step you got to
you can't be doing comedy if you think
you're stupid and not funny so believe
in that when you're doing improv and
off-the-cuff stuff believe in you're
funny so even when it's not going well
on the improv side it's almost just like
pressing through that discomfort
correct correct but that's what I was
saying and that's a little cheat code
fall back is having a joke that you know
is good that pertains to people
relationship a job children something
like that yeah so just have that
fallback so if things aren't going like
you thought of things are getting slow
you're like all right let me get to this
relationship joke that I have by making
it seem like I made it up by talking to
these two people right right yeah coz
I'll sometimes I try to improv on stage
but then I still kind of get stuck in
the rut of material as well and I'll be
improvising a bit I'm gonna improvise
this whole five minute thing about what
happened and in 30 seconds and you're
like this is
but that's not but it's not it's not bad
to weave your your set that's kind of
what I'm trying to say like we eat jokes
from your set into the crowd work you
know I'm saying thank you look like
you're making that joke up that you've
done a hundred times right there for
them that's gold yeah yeah you you being
legitimately I mean the first time I saw
you hosting I was just like yo this guy
this guy's got the the goods he's got
the funny I appreciate and hosting is
something you learn a lot about and if
we want to segue into our question I was
gonna say we just better than 400 and
having a sift through all that but I
feel you I feel you
good point Newton once but I appreciate
you bringing me back down to earth and
be like no 4 is good and I was excited
about getting those but then I don't
know where tomorrow and I feel like with
him you I'm with you so I felt like I
had to be like cool or whatever it's not
the moment but you know how you get
around I don't know I'm just as we both
wore like the same thing to the show
every week had a uniform we did all the
way but you got to pay your dues in the
beginning comics got to all that [ __ ]
comes back around believe that yes all
the free stuff your dog is telling
expensive Neal one of my favorite young
comics about that day I seen him kind of
like well as months ago we kinda like
him to write about things you know how
comedy gets and I was just like you're
all the little things you're doing for
free and things like they ain't worth it
the [ __ ] comes back around see that
somebody that's working on it for it
they saw how you showed up you
professional you were funny actually
comes back around facts mm-hmm so in
touching on hosting which is where I've
learned a lot of my comfort onstage and
my improv and things like that
a Julie mara tech shout out she's a
she's a local new comic actually an alum
actually yeah and she asked what are the
what are the best and worst parts of
hosting alright shout out Julie I know
who she is she's funny
she's very funny yes indeed she's got it
what are the best and worst parts about
hosting mm-hmm
I mean most of the best parts I already
mentioned in terms of so like if you're
a new comic you're trying to get like
you know 30 at 30 minutes per week you
know I'm saying like so say you hit six
spots for five minutes a week that's
probably what you can get in Atlanta in
New York you get more but so for Atlanta
comedians you could probably get 30
minutes a week the best part about
hosting is you could get that 30 minutes
in a day and then go get 30 other
minutes so now you got an hour a week
that you've been onstage that's the best
part
um improv in crowd work is another part
cuz that's kind of like on you to do
more than the people that's been working
on their sets so that's another good
part I'm struggling because I'm trying
to think of a bad thing a bad part to
hosting yeah I've got ya dealing with
comedians when hi correct there's one
correct you know what I've been hosting
so long I got numb to that but I
remember when I first started how much I
hated and I used to and is funny seeing
like the young comedians that used to do
it to me and it's to get their own room
and I would look at their face and lo
you got a whole space yeah that's the
only real bad part but I never trip
about it because I know how important
getting on stage is so I never really
like trip about it it may be a little
aggravating but hopefully no one's ever
felt I've never shown that to any comics
especially in young new comics out there
that I was aggravated because I know I
know what you mean I know what you're
trying to do yeah so stay with it don't
get an attitude about it I say but stay
with stay being mad about not getting on
stage have that keep that hunger yeah
I'm sad say don't show it but stay like
okay I'm gonna show them keep that in
there oh yeah I've sat around the show
for three hours
to go up dead last when everybody left
or go up after the show ended I was like
yo you said I was going up those shows
over I was like well give me the mic
I'll still be lost I just went up after
the show mmm-hmm like many times yeah
for free do it do it yeah a note you had
on hosting in the last episode was you
would host these show you would host
shows for free because like if you're
gonna do it for free anyway might as
well do it on your turn
correct so right yeah I recommend
everybody go and get your time in you
know I'm saying it's a little more
valuable if you're getting your time in
then you know using your gas go three
four spots to get there five fifteen
minutes exactly yeah yeah I can't I
can't think of any worse maybe unless
the show is all on you it's like it's
kind of your responsibility yeah getting
the crowd shows what they wanted me to
be like the promoter
- yeah but hosting is pretty much legit
all the way around and it's just
promoting a venue what you just be like
hey I'm I want to host this comedy show
on like one of your down nights and be
you know comedies booming here in
Atlanta you could almost sell the scene
to them and say you'll do it for free
upfront and then see if you can build a
following as long as I help you build
the audience and then you can talk about
money from there
correct correct yeah build your audience
man cuz you know this place is a bunch
of places in Atlanta especially right
now in the summertime they're gonna be
opening and just having people in there
I have a slow night if you get there
night jumping you can you can make it
work and yeah and we need we need
another spot in Atlanta we need another
yeah I you know I'm saying we need
another job a monkey we need another
cats you know I'm saying cuz there's so
many comedians out here and a lot of
comedy fans you know I mean that they
need a place to go in CPU exactly yeah
any other buddy else and other scenes
you know you can always use more shows I
would say it can only help nurture the
scene right bro right that's my that's
my two cents on that good question
though yes indeed the only other one was
from Lee Lee oh yes Vanessa fractions
sister who's been on here but she said
well she spelled it fuq so I'm not
really sure what that
is but she said why the few are you
leaving the foot helis
and it's to go to LA right yeah why are
you leaving us is what she said going
out to where well my man I know you're
extremely busy you've been filming
Wilding out this entire week yeah who
took your day off to do this so I
appreciate your time I appreciate you
having me may I always have butter for
people anybody especially my peers to be
like yo man I need you on my shelf
that's gonna change a man we saw you
brother before we get out of here is
there anything else you want the world
to know a man hot brethren keep letting
people know about my boys show first and
foremost his podcast the live comedy hey
is my is my gonna air yeah Oh yours will
be on there for sure so so you're doing
it like a series I'm just like I do the
show every week every Wednesday at Java
monkey in Decatur Georgia at 8:00 p.m.
dunno but I record as a live podcast so
every week I'm just gonna roll another
one out suppose this one Monday and I'm
thinking I'll post that one on Fridays
all right perfect and then so yeah yours
will be on there and what was messed up
about yours is that was really mean and
kind of cutting in that one and it was
killing the next week I try to do the
same thing no not at all they were in
here from Mean Joe keep watching um
Tyler Chronicles is how you follow me on
everything and see what I got going on
season 12 of Wilin out so it's not a
season coming up that they filmed
already but it will be seen 12 Wilin out
by sup on WE tv coming in August really
excited about that big AF tour and
August as well college students I'll be
coming to a college near you starting
August it's gonna be a surgical summer
were to push T
my man Tyler chronic my guy jay pizzle
thanks for being on hot breath you know
[Music]